see and Kevin Hart was all set to host
the Academy Awards and he's a funny guy
what happened there Laura the Academy
wanted and and ABC wanted just what they
did in the case of Roseanne Barr
a larger-than-life edgy act that would
draw a big audience but when controversy
followed they ran for the exits let's go
back to 2010 this is a bit of Kevin
Hart's act so you see what ABC knew they
were getting into watch my biggest fears
is my son growing up and being gay if I
can prevent my son from being gay
I will every kid has a gay moment okay
every kid but when it happens you got to
nip it in the bud you got to stop it
right there
stop that's good now Hart also wrote
similar tweets and over the years ABC
and the Academy had to know this now
they fired a director remember a few
years back from making an anti-gay slur
on Twitter and you will remember why
they probably hired Hart he's a beloved
african-american performer in this age
of Oscars so white and because of what
he said at the MTV Video Music Awards
Laura earlier this year you'll remember
he sided with the NFL kneelers and he
told the president quote trump suck it
well heavily the Academy loved the Trump
bashing edgy crass hell art until
Hollywood and the community started
pushing back on social media calling him
homophobic anti-gay and they reached out
to heart watch he's got a call from the
Academy and that call basically said
Kevin apologize for your tweets of old
or we're gonna have to move on to find
another hose it's all about the tweets
from 2009-2010 I showed the past I
passed on your part
reason why passes because I've addressed
this several times he decided not to
apologize he said I'm not gonna
apologize
he eventually collapsed and he did
apologize but what this demonstrates ABC
which is the network involved and the
Academy Awards they did not learn the
Roseanne Barr lesson which is when the
PC Dogma moves in and makes demands on
you stand firm you can get people to
apologize for outrageous things but you
can't collapse and throw your talent
overboard or comedy then the lane for
comedy is going to narrow well nobody
wants hate but give people an option
give them an hour what did we just play
was it last night from Jerry Seinfeld
what he was on we have another clip of
Jeff a longer clip watch this because it
speaks to justice issue comedy is by its
nature dangerous it doesn't and in that
clip with Kevin Hart just before we go
on he sounds like he's he's carrot he's
like a self caricatures it's comedy you
don't really believe what he's saying
he's just trying to have a make a fun
moment and I understand how people would
say that's not and I get it but he the
idea that he actually that's the way he
really fits this Seinfeld I do this joke
about the way people need that justify
their cellphone I need to have it with
me because people are so important right
you know I said well they don't seem
very important the way you scroll
through them like a gay French King what
do you mean gay what are you - am i gay
what he said gay what do you what do you
do what do you what do you mean you know
and I thought are you kidding me this is
the problem everybody's so sensitive we
need to have our foibles and who we are
Lampoon so we can laugh together and get
sad the bias everyone good laugh but he
took my Don Rickles would he be although
mic reforms and Rickles would never be
able to leave the house don't go to
college campus because humour is dead
you cannot forget it